l'habitat de demain itinéraire bis
dimanche à 10h45 sur public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue à bruxelles au
coeur du parlement européen pour ce
nouveau numéro de rater le dos et sur ce
plateau dans quelques instants nous
allons parler du dumping social on
connaît le phénomène des plombiers
polonais mais il ya aussi des chauffeurs
routiers polonais ils sont très nombreux
sur les routes de notre continent
reportage dans un instant mais d'abord
l'actualité les européens et le fonds
monétaire international ont volé au
secours de la grèce qui était une fois
de plus au bord du gouffre mais cette
aide va t'elle suffire c'est la question
de la semaine la grèce attendait depuis
six mois l'aide promise par ses
partenaires
asphyxiée par sa dette elle a besoin
d'argent frais pour payer ses
fonctionnaires ses retraités et faire
tourner l'économie
les réunions se succèdent à bruxelles en
vain les bailleurs de fonds d'athènes
échoue à régler le casse-tête grec
laissant le pays au bord de la faillite
et puis le 26 novembre les créanciers de
la grèce reviennent au chevet du malade
treize heures de discussions intenses
difficile et au bout de la nuit surprise
un accord est conclu les ministres de la
zone euro et les représentants du fonds
monétaire international estiment que le
pays qui a fait voter un nouveau plan de
rigueur remplit les conditions pour le
versement d'une aide
on a énormément travaillé
nous nous sommes vu trois fois et
pendant deux nuits
oui des doutes mais nous l'avons fait et
aujourd'hui c'est un bon jour pour les
membres de l'eurozone
mission accomplie téteux jobs la dette
grecque sera ramené à 124 % du produit
intérieur brut d'ici 2020 ce qui fait un
allègement de 40 milliards d'euros
athènes recevra aussi 43 milliards
d'euros dead en plusieurs tranches
elle aura aussi plus de temps pour
rembourser sa dette une fois de plus les
européens ont volé au secours de leurs
partenaires mais dans six mois le pays
se retrouvera peut-être encore à court
d'argent parce que sa dette aura
augmenté et que les caisses seront vides
alors à quoi bon aider la grèce
voilà alors cette semaine le regard d'un
député britannique sur l'actualité
européenne graham watson bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président du parti des
libéraux et démocrates pour l'europe
donc européen convaincu et très
impliquée ici au parlement européen
on a entendu le ministre français de
l'économie et des finances pierre
moscovici qui s'exprime et d'ailleurs en
anglais il estime que ce qui s'est passé
récemment à l'eurogroupe est un tournant
pour la crise grecque
est ce que vous partagez son sentiment
oui je partage cette idée il c'est vrai
que beaucoup mettent en question le coup
de sauver la grèce mais le coup de ne
pas sauver la grèce pourrait être
beaucoup plus haut nous sommes dans une
position où les allemands en premier
lieu mais tout le monde a décidé que la
grèce doit rester au sein de l'euro les
grecs même on trouvait la discipline
pour faire ce qu'il faut et donc nous
irons de ce point là pour l'avenir il
c'est vrai que sur ce même plateau il ya
quelques mois on se disait la même chose
on disait la grèce est au bord du
gouffre il faut à nouveau donner de
l'argent
les européens donnaient delà de l'argent
on a l'impression que c'est jamais
suffisant est ce que cette fois-là la
somme donnée l'allègement de dette
consentis
des taux d'intérêt plus ou parce que
toutes ces mesures là vont vraiment
suffire à ce que vont vraiment suffire
pour qu'athènes puisse se relever
je pense qu'ils doivent suffire nous
avons maintenant aussi l'expérience que
porte le fmi dont ces choses là et je
pense que nous avons un plan qui va
remettre la grèce sur la bonne voie mais
s'il ya une différence
une grande différence entre la situation
actuelle et la situation d'ici un an
enfin il y a un nom c'est que là la
détermination politique en europe existe
ce qui n'était pas tout à fait le cas il
ya un an et l'allemagne n'était pas
forcément très partante pour aider la
grèce
finalement le le fait que l'allemagne
est accepté d'aider les grecs a raconté
c'est difficile parce que à la fin c'est
eux qui ont la capacité de sauver la
grèce mais évidemment ils doivent
confronter aussi leurs électeurs je
trouve qu'ils ont fait leur la bonne le
bon choix et j'espère qu'un gouvernement
allemand aura la reconnaissance aux
urnes pour ce qui a été fait est ce que
vous pensez que les grecs ont fait
assez d'effort est ce que les
changements donc on attendait d'athènes
on se sont se sont fait par exemple sur
le front de la corruption notamment
je pense que ce que fait le gouvernement
actuel en grèce ce sont des mesures très
important pour lutter contre la
corruption
pour bien prendre les impôts que les
gens ne paient pas dans le passé ils ont
fait une série de rohff réforme aussi de
réduire les coûts de l'état welfare en
grèce
reste à voir si les grecs supporter les
mesures qui vont être mises en place
et si la grèce ne les supporte pas il ne
s'agit pas de rester ou ne pas rester au
sein de l'euro mais plutôt de rester ou
ne pas rester au sein de l'union
européenne
et pour vous c'est la seule voie
possible continuer à être solidaire
d'athènes même si il faut à chaque fois
donné de plus en plus d'argent pour
aider la grèce c'est la seule solution
pour que la la zone euro survive
nous sommes solidaires avec lisbonne
nous sommes solidaires avec dublin
nous sommes solidaires avec madrid avec
nico cia il faut être solidaire aussi
avec athènes la grèce fait partie de
l'union européenne et on veut que ceci
reste le cas alors on va ouvrir une page
de plus international on va rejoindre
dans un instant un collègue qui nous
parlera spécifiquement de la situation
au mali moi je voulais vous interroger
sur la palestine puisque il ya une
réunion importante qui se décident en ce
moment à l'onu au sujet
le statut du fameux statut de l'état
palestinien
la france a dit qu'elle reconnaîtrait
les européens sont la position
européenne est plus floue vous-même que
dites vous est ce que la palestine doit
devenir le 194e état les nations unies
je pense que la position de la france
qui est d'ailleurs la même que la
position du parlement européen qui a
voté la semaine dernière c'est que la
palestine doit être reconnu par l'onu
comme un état
ce ne sera pas un état membre des
nations unies comme d'autres mais
l'important c'est que ceux qui étaient
contenues dans les résolutions du
conseil de sécurité 242 et les autres
soient reconnus officiellement par
l'assemblée dans l'assemblée de l'onu
en tout cas au moins elle aura un statut
ce qui n'est pas le cas actuellement
elle remet lancé que c'est ce sera ça va
compter ce sera uniquement symbolique
nous sommes dans une position
extrêmement difficile au proche orient
est d'abord puisque les israéliens ont
d'un gouvernement qui est assez extrêmes
les américains interviennent pas comme
ils sont intervenus dans le passé pour
restreindre les actions de l'israël il
faut que les européennes jouent un rôle
plus important et donc la reconnaissance
du palestine fait partie d'une approche
globale beaucoup plus forte de l'union b
et bien on suivra cette question merci
beaucoup graham watson d'avoir été avec
nous sur le plateau d' europe hebdo tout
de suite donc le zapping des télés
européennes avec un focus sur la
situation au mali
c'est dans cette commune rurale de diéma
à la frontière avec la mauritanie que
l'enlèvement s'est produit ce
ressortissant français a franchi hier
vers 11 heures le poste frontière de
gogui il venait de s'arrêter dans une
radio locale de diéma pour se connecter
à internet
quand il a été enlevé par plusieurs
hommes armés il y à une intervention
militaire qui se prépare donc pour eux
des terroristes capturé un otage c'est
un moyen de faire pression
on ne la pensait pas possible avant au
moins plusieurs mois mais l'intervention
militaire au mali ne serait plus qu'une
question de semaines
selon le ministre français de la défense
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
a donné mandat au pays d'afrique de
l'ouest de s'organiser pour qu'il y ait
une intervention afin de rétablir la
souveraineté du mali officiellement on
joue encore la carte de la diplomatie
mais sur le terrain les grandes
manoeuvres ont déjà commencé pour
reconquérir le nord du mali une région
grande comme 20 fois la suisse sous le
contrôle de mouvances islamistes qui ont
fait voler l'unité du mali en éclats et
instaurer la charia à chaos vers
tombouctou la perle du désert
cette offensive islamiste n'est pas
nouvelle au contraire afrique de l'ouest
1836 oumar tall chef de l'état guerrière
des toucouleurs rentre d'un pèlerinage à
la mecque et d'un séjour à l'université
coranique al azhar du caire
sa décision est prise il va lancer un
jihad il lève alors une armée de
transmit l'homme avec laquelle il se
taille un empire dans l'actuel mali
voilà pour ce petit tour d'horizon un
nouvel invité est avec nous nicolas gros
verheyde bonjour bonjour vous êtes
correspondant à bruxelles pour ouest
france mais vous tenez un blog sur la
défense européenne vous êtes bien
renseigné sur ce qui se passe
ce qui se prépare en tout cas au mali
une opération pour libérer le nord du
pays de l'emprise de groupe djihadiste
armé
on va pas rentrer dans les détails mais
dites-nous en quelques mots quelle sera
la participation des européens à ce
dispositif
il faut bien voir qu'il ya trois
opérations en une il faut il ya quand
même trois opérations distinctes la
participation des européens va se
concentrer sur le renforcement la la
restructuration la remise sur pied de
l'armée malienne avec des formateurs
environ 250 militaires qui vont partir à
bamako et aux environs pour aller
refermer l'armée malienne et la
restructurer un peu ce qu'ont fait les
européens en ouganda avec l'armée
somalienne est quelque chose qui se
poursuit qu'il ya eu un certain succès
c'est une mission d'accompagnement
c'est une mission j'irai on va dire de
coopération militaire c'est le lea
solitaire assez classique finalement
très classique
les européens vont pas la baptiser comme
ça mais c'est c'est uniquement comme ça
il y aura pas que les européens
normalement il pourrait y avoir d'autres
d'autres pays non européens les
canadiens auraient été approchés ils
pourraient aussi participer parce qu'ils
ont été très présents au mali la
deuxième opération c'est celle de la
cedeao donc des pays africains l'afrique
de l'ouest avec d'autres pays qui lave à
venir j'irai d'abord sécuriser le sud
est ensuite remonté éventuellement est
remonté sur le nord donc là les
européens en tant qu'entité ne vont pas
fournir dead mais chacun des pays
effectivement fournir un appui
logistique de renseignement transport
aérien il est évident que l'opération ne
veut pas se monter comme ça tout seul
pour comprendre il n'y aura pas de
soldats européens n'y aura pas de
soldats au combat
il y aura une mathématiquement il faut
bien des des militaires au sol pour
guider et pour assurer
rien que pour aussi du transport
stratégique il faut bien que les avions
atterrissent que c'est bien une mission
logistique mais là on a une mission
logistique direct d'accompagnement assez
lourde et sans doute avec des des forces
spéciales des forces de renseignement et
les africains n'ont pas de soi y ait une
liste donnée par la cedeao aux
différents alliés il ya l'onu
officiellement et donc les différents
pays de l'onu vont s'appeler et ensuite
il ya un dialogue politique assez gérer
musclé qui va essayer des pressions qui
vont essayer d'amener les mouvements
rebelles
à ceux-ci sio nez et à ceux il ya
s'asseoir à la table d'un giada mme
ashton la haute représentante
ce dialogue enfin c'est ce qu'elle
participe à cette opération pas du tout
ce qu'il ya un dialogue qui s'instaure
pour l'instant le l'europe réfléchisse
et à son problème elle est quand même en
retard d'une guerre elle a réfléchi à la
nomination d'un représentant spécial au
sahel qui en fait serait à même de mener
ces négociations faut savoir qu'il ya
des gens entre guillemets européen qui
est nommé représentant spécial au nom de
l'onudc et romano prodi qui va d'une
certaine façon est effectué cette
combinaison là et bien merci nicolas
gros verheyde pour cet éclairage est
claire je renvoie sur votre blog
bruxelles 2 pour plus d'informations et
on retrouve tout de suite françois
beaudonnet sont invités après ce
reportage inédit sur une pratique
douteuse de plus en plus de sociétés
belges ou françaises embauche des
chauffeurs routiers venus de certains
pays de l'est et cela à très bas prix et
dans des conditions dangereuses pour la
sécurité routière
c'est une enquête signée ilana azencott
et yoann là
une autoroute au sud de la belgique
la pluie toujours la pluie grégory 53
ans a passé plus de la moitié de sa vie
ici dans la cabine de son camion a
sillonné l'europe jusqu'au moyen-orient
ce soir là pourtant la mission de ce
chauffeur indépendant m'a plus grand
chose d'exotique une cinquantaine de
kilomètres à peine entre liège et namur
fatah je partais les vrais élus et puis
j'ai fait un ramassage des oeufs
ça peut faire tourner autour de l'elysée
lui à ajoie il y a quatre ans grégory
était à la tête d'une entreprise
florissante cinq personnes travaillaient
pour lui aujourd'hui
ce patron n'a même plus de quoi se
verser un salaire de chauffeurs son
avenir s'écrit comme les lignes de la
route en pointillés c'est plus possible
parce qu'elle a les réponses à l'heure
actuelle c'est bon ben si vous ne faites
pas ça lituaniens ou un slovaque ou à
cake ou à polonais
j'ai envie d'arriver j'ai envie de tout
de tout plaquer c'est un métier que
j'adore je serais rien faire d'autre
mais je suis dégoûtée je suis dégoûtée
sur fond d'ouverture des frontières et
de libéralisation des transports la
chute a été brutale
ce soir là les concurrents de grégory ne
dorme qu'à quelques mètres à la lisière
de l'autoroute a9 qui sont immatriculés
il avait insulté une fois dans l'ouest
mais avant ça il était une fois dans
l'est
rauno externe
si cette main d'oeuvre low cost est venu
par la route
c'est à proximité du plus grand port du
pays qu'elle a trouvé refuge sur les
docks d'anvers ce jour là
des centaines de chauffeurs attente d'un
abri des regards leurs marchandises
ici les journalistes ne sont pas les
bienvenus
c'est en caméra cachée que nous allons à
leur rencontre là c'est les tchèques
l'ukraine et les slovaques sont ici à
gauche
une de ces polonais de poznan s'apprête
à passer à table à l'arrière d'un camion
sur le parking pas de cuisine seulement
trois wc et de douches pour plus de 500
personnes
on dort dans le camion on mange dans le
camion faut se battre pour les toilettes
oui c'est difficile difficile et
quelques minutes plus tard une autre
question plus embarrassante encore vous
attendez ici depuis longtemps
quatre semaines 4 au non dit pas ça ah
bon il ya trois jours
mieux vaut mentir car rester quatre
semaines c'est illégal
un chauffeur étrangers à sept jours pour
quitter le pays mais sans gps facile de
tricher un peu plus loin
ce chauffeur roumain a lui aussi dépassé
le délai son salaire de base
150 euros fixe c'est pas un salaire fixe
vous êtes payés au kilomètre oui c'est
pas correct
ma compagnie fait de gros profits sur
notre dos des primes au kilomètre
autant dire une incitation à rouler là
encore la législation plafonne la
conduite à 10 heures par jour mais pour
espérer gagner plus beaucoup de
conducteurs de l'est falsifient les
données de leurs compteurs électroniques
difficile de prendre la mesure des
fraudes
seule certitude pour ces travailleurs
précaires l'histoire va parfois beaucoup
plus loin sur ses terres de repos il y a
deux ans presque jour pour jour ce
permanent syndical de la fgtb équivalent
belge de la cgt a dû intervenir pour
régler une situation sans précédent ont
peur qu'on voit que tous les chauffeurs
qui sont en majorité des slovaques sur
cet hebdo c'est seulement ça fait trois
mois qu'ils ont pas été payés
on leur demande on leur demande de
descendre de leur camion une vingtaine
de slovaques tombé du camion et très
vite pour philippe dumortier une autre
surprise derrière leur société un
employant berne le représentant légal
donc ne se devine vos clés avec un
salaire mensuel 497 euros des sociétés
belges auraient tel recours à ce dôme
ping
c'est le début d'une longue enquête fait
unique en europe début 2012 le syndicat
seront à bratislava
équipé d'une caméra cachée cet homme se
fait passer pour un employeur souhaitant
implanter une société fictive
c'est un tout petit bâtiment y lire 250
soucis et les à l'intérieur donc fait
c'est illogique parce qu'il n'ya pas de
150 bureaux dans ce type de bateau non
l'accord n'est par contre il ya toute
une série de boîtes aux lettres juste
derrière la porte vitrée là et le nombre
de boîtes aux lettres est assez
impressionnant
pour alain durand la pêche est
miraculeuse sur les murs de boîtes aux
lettres des centaines de filiales
fictive de société bien réel venu faire
le plein de travailleurs dans un pays à
la fiscalité avantageuse
c'est illégal étant donné que la société
n'est pas dirigée depuis le pays qui a
aucun camion sur le territoire mohawk
certainement un point à point capital un
article capital qui donnerait la
possibilité à pays membres de la
communauté européenne de porter plainte
sera notre état problème de moyens ou de
volonté politique
malgré l'entorse directive européenne
mais poursuit tu resteras dans un an
les syndicats redoutent même une
nouvelle déréglementation des transports
une aubaine pour les grands groupes
synonyme de disparition pour les plus
fragiles
voilà pour cette enquête édifiante signé
yoan or la pervenche berès bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
française vous êtes socialiste quand on
voit ce qu'on vient de voir dans ce
reportage des chauffeurs de l'est de
l'europe qui sont payés 500 euros par
mois
est-ce que c'est pas ce genre de
phénomène qui participent de manque de
popularité de l'europe est clair c'est
pas ça qui va brouiller l'image de
l'europe mais vous avez totalement
raison
et ce dossier des transporteurs routiers
leur temps de travail c'est le premier
dossier dont j'ai eu à me saisir lorsque
j'ai été élu président de la commission
emploi et affaires sociales en 2009
or derrière tout ça il ya la question de
savoir comment est ce que les états
membres acceptent de progresser en
matière de lutte contre le dumping
social c'est aussi un débat entre états
membres
mais n'oublions pas que derrière il ya
parfois me semble-t-il la question de
savoir si c'est une majorité
progressiste ou pas qui est aux
responsabilités donc je voudrais pas que
lorsque nous aurons un rendez vous en
eh bien on brouille les cartes si nous
voulons avancer dans ce sens là eh bien
nous avons aussi besoin d'avoir une
majorité plus progressistes sur
parlement mais les citoyens européens
qui regardent ce reportage et qui
connaissent la réalité parce que c'est
un phénomène dans le kiosque routier
mais on le voit aussi dans le bâtiment
on le voit aussi dans le nettoyage
il ya énormément de secteurs c'est comme
ça mais qu'est ce que vous dites est ce
que c'est je dirais la faute de l'europe
ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui
en tout cas c'est une c'est parce qu'il
manque un outil dans la construction
européenne qui est tous bien toute la
question de la dimension sociale s'est
pas assez d'europe ou au contraire c'est
trop d'europe et bien sûr que c'est pas
assez d'europe parce que lorsqu'on a
fait l'élargissement
le rhône est ouvert les frontières les
routes ça paraît normal on veut pas
devoir faire l'élargissement remettent
des frontières à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne c'est totalement contraire à
toute l'idée de l'union européenne y
compris dans la libre circulation des
personnes
mais derrière ça veut dire qu'il faut
progresser dans
médiation sociale en 2002 il y à une
législation qui rentre et qui a été
élaborée qui est entré en vigueur en
2009 qui prévoit de contrôler dans le
domaine des transporteurs routiers ce
qu'on appelle les indépendants or cette
législation
la commission veut la corriger pour
exclure les indépendants du champ
d'application de cette directive et le
parlement refuse et cela ça a été une
victoire très important mais la
difficulté c'est que la commission ne
sanctionne pas les états membres qu'ils
ne contrôlent pas vers l'indépendance
d'avec là si je puis me permets de vous
me faites de la cuisine interne
européenne mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire à ses chauffeurs routiers c'est
indépendant il y avait un chauffeurs
routiers indépendants qui sont en train
de perdre leur travail à toute une
filière
par exemple en france mais aussi en
belgique qui est en train de disparaître
parce que justement il ya une invasion à
long terme est un peu est un peu barbare
mais en tout cas de ses chauffeurs
routiers venus l'est qu'est ce qu'on
peut leur dire est ce que les choses
avancent et ce qu'ils vont être protégés
ou est-ce que c'est fini pour eux en
tout cas je peux vous dire que ici nous
nous battons mais nous ne sommes pas
toujours majoritaire pour le faire donc
c'est bien une question politique
il faut transformer la donne et
permettre que ceux qui sont en faveur de
davantage d'harmonisation sociale soit
majoritaire au parlement européen à la
commission
je m'excuse c'est notre cuisine de
gouvernance mais c'est le rapport de fer
qui permettra d'avancer sur ces
questions ce que vous avez monté dans le
reportage c'est très significatif
ce sont aussi des sociétés belges
françaises ou autres qui ont développé
des filiales dans ces pays pour
bénéficier des conditions sociales et
fiscales de recrutement de faux
indépendants qui viennent ensuite faire
concurrence aux travailleurs dans ce que
vous le dites c'est que c'est un peu
facile de jeter la pierre sur les pays
de l'est de l'est de l'europe mais qu'il
ya ici de ce côté de l'europe des gens
qui ont profité bien sûr lorsque une
société belge française multiplie les
filiales en slovaquie ou en pologne
on va recruter des personnes sur place
aux conditions de travail sur place
c'est bien une condition qui contribuent
à ce qu'est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elles
ont choix si elles le font pas de toute
façon on peut dire que d'autres le
le front est est ce qu'elles ont le
choix réellement le choix on l'a
toujours la question c'est de savoir
comment est ce qu'on se marre ensuite
pour harmoniser les conditions
c'est important pour eux en termes de
concurrence c'est aussi majeures en
termes de condition sociale car vous
avez vu les conditions de vie de ces
gens on peut pas considérer ces
chauffeurs routiers peut pas considérer
que ce soit digne d'un modèle social
européen
mais c'est aussi une question de
sécurité routière parce que ces
chauffeurs dans ces conditions de
travail sur les routes doivent faire de
milo m absolument alors on va regarder
écouter une question qui est posée
justement à votre attention par ce
syndicaliste belge
et puis ensuite on revient avec vous en
écoutant le règlement qui régit la
plantation d'une société de transport
dans un pays membre de la communauté
européenne stipule certaines choses et
notamment que la société doit disposer
dans ce même pays d'un bâtiment
administratif et d'un bâtiment technique
or ce que nous avons constaté à
bratislava lors de notre expédition
début 2012
c'est tout simplement que ces sociétés
n'existe pas où elles existent
uniquement sur papier que compter que
comptez vous faire pour résorber ce
problème là pour anéantir tout
simplement la fraude fiscale et la
fraude sociale qui est organisée
alors qu'avant je verrai ce quelle est
votre réponse
c'est une très bonne question parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle la pratique des
sociétés boîte à lettres c'est à dire
une coquille vide
pour cela il faut à la fois je vous le
disais que la commission européenne
lutte contre les faux indépendants
qu'elle oblige les états membres à
contrôler ce qui se passe dans le
secteur des transports comme dans
d'autres secteurs par exemple dans le
secteur de la construction où ce type de
phénomène existe aussi
il faut que la chaîne de responsabilités
soient définies parce qu'aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il est à ses filiales ses
sociétés boîte à lettres et bien bien
souvent la société mère ne s'occupe pas
de ce qui se passe dans la finale il
faut qu'elle soit responsable aussi des
conditions d'application de la
législation
et puis il faut une progression pour que
la question des conditions de travail de
durée de travail puisse être mieux
harmoniser au niveau européen faut
savoir que propositions que nous avons
rejeté prévoyait par exemple des
indépendants puissent travailler donc
officiellement entre 84 voir vous pouvez
travailler 84 voire 80 6 heures par
semaine alors quelle est la limite entre
la légalité et l'illégalité ces
compagnies qui font ça qui font
travailler des chauffeurs alors on
disait polonais mais ces slovaques aussi
également est ce qu'elles sont dans la
légalité ou est ce qu elles sont
carrément dans l'illégalité n'ont
manifestement quand on voit les
conditions de vie de c'est
chauffeur routier ne peut pas considérer
que ce soit la légalité mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des failles dans le degré
d'harmonisation sociale qui est tout le
sait beaucoup beaucoup développée que la
libre circulation des biens et des
marchandises qui conduisent à ces
situations où de telles failles peuvent
peuvent peuvent se développer alors ce
sont des failles qui sont liées à la
législation européenne
en revanche ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de contrôles en tous cas pas
assez et ses contrôles dans le monde
doivent être faits par les états membres
ont donc en l'occurrence par la france
ou par la belgique pourquoi est ce que
ces états membres ne le font pas parce
qu'une certaine manière il ya une
complicité où ils protègent leur secteur
national et c'est là où je pense que la
commission a oui si une stabilité
attendue en danger bien comprendre le
fait de ne pas contrôler les chauffeurs
routiers slovaques ou polonais en france
c'est pour protéger le secteur national
non c'est un espèce de il ya des
contrôles qui sont exercées il faut
aussi savoir que dans les conditions du
gher budgétaire ces contrôles sont
chères sont parfois difficiles à
organiser créer des climats tension sur
les lieux de circulation de
confrontation entre chauffeurs on l'a
très bien vu dans votre reportage qui
rend les choses difficiles mais ici au
niveau du parlement repères moi ce que
je constate aussi c'est que la
commission européenne ou
ne développe pas les outils qu'elle a
vis-à-vis des états membres qui
n'appuient pas bien la législation
notamment le fait que les indépendants
doivent être couverts par la législation
en matière de temps de travail
le message est envoyé à josé manuel
barroso le président de la commission
européenne
également je verrai ce merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté l'invitation d'europe
hebdo c'est la fin de cette émission on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine d'ici
là bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires